this is an okapi
they may look like zebras but they are
actually the only living relative of
giraffes
endemic to the democratic republic of
congo the okapi is a solitary animal
that lives only in dense forests
their coloring is distinctive
their deep red coat contrasts with black
and white markings across their hind
side and legs
these specific markings act as
camouflage among the trees
similar to giraffes okapis have long
tongues that they use to pull leaves
from branches
their tongues are between 14 and 18
inches in length
so long that they can clean their ears
and eyes with it
the okapi are known for having
incredible hearing
their large ears can detect the
slightest disturbance around them which
helps protect them from predators
it is believed that in the last decade
okapi populations have been halved due
to deforestation and hunting
the presence of armed groups in their
native habitat makes conservation
efforts nearly impossible but local
governments are stepping up the okapi is
a fully protected species under
congolese law and is a national symbol
for the country
this is an okapi
[Music]
you